let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let's go first to Jose who we have
not heard from since January Jose what's
going on hey what are you doing good how
are you I'm going good no I got help I
want to get your thoughts on the
fascination of them of this
administration using the military I
spawned my my thing was the whole issue
with Eddie Gallagher being pardoned for
war crimes yes and yeah and just today a
daily peace article would put out where
Donald Trump wants to use these war
criminals as essentially kept his
campaign motivation going forward yep he
wants them to go and campaign for him
and this is so listen this this is the
reality
earlier this week Trump did a press
conference with a military dog and it's
cleared Trump doesn't care about the dog
it's just how can I use the dog to try
to look good it's always about what can
you do for Trump nothing is about actual
values or political philosophy because
Trump really has none and case in point
it was absolutely ridiculous that Donald
Trump said hey war criminals doesn't
matter you can get out but now you need
to do work for me and you need to
campaign for me by the way who said this
is totally aside from whether it would
benefit Trump to have pardoned war
criminals campaigning for him maybe it
would help him with people on the right
I don't think people on the left would
be too thrilled with that but what we
get down to is it's just all about what
can you do for Trump how can you excuse
me how can you show your unending
loyalty to Trump and if he's done you a
favor of some kind then how are you
going to repay him right along with
bribery in other words that's how I love
these guys yeah you're right I
just can't tell I don't know why people
don't see that I know I know a couple
people that I serves I can see right
through that but there's many others
that just they see this as to when they
see this as hey there I says hey there
and if there's the enemy anyway right
tears yep this is so and when Trump
worked in real estate this is how he
operated he would that this is how Trump
operated in real estate this is what
happened with Ukraine this is what's
happening here it's it's what happens
with and by the way with with
ambassadorships it's bigger than Trump
this is just how ambassadorships work in
the United States and it's sickening but
this is how the guy operates that's it
you've identified it right yeah thank
you for taking my call David um I just
wanna let you know that I'm a writer
listener and I'm pretty active and onion
subreddit so thank you all right very
good great to hear from you appreciate
the call